what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
february 17th the joint is brought to
you by
relief band do you know that a third of
americans regularly suffer from nausea
i don't usually have nausea but when i
had the surgery
you got to take the oxygens you got that
that synthetic heroin
and you got to puke i started you know
it's the truth it's synthetic heroin so
you get sick i don't usually get nausea
but i get it after the surgery before i
got the surgery
i got a box in the mail i thought it was
like one of my friends bob
sent me like a box for the surgery it
was relief band
the premiere clinically proven i mean
this is tremendous
this is why i'm excited about our new
partner relief band because relief ban
is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea
wrist band that has been clinically
proven to relieve
and prevent nausea and vomiting how do i
know
because the one day i didn't wear it to
pt
on the way back i puked in the car i got
carsick
that's how i know this works and i've
kept it on
every day since my surgery
this kind of thing is only available to
hospital patients
but now it's available to everybody that
means you
this is how it works relief band
stimulates a nerve in the wrist
that travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach
by telling you that you're sick science
relief band is the only over-the-counter
wearable band that has been used in
hospitals
and oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting
like i told you in the beginning man uh
i saw recuperation
so i put it on i didn't really suffer
from nausea but
when you start taking those pills all
those i mean 13 prescriptions
you're going to get something you know
what i'm saying thank god for relief ban
so
do yourself a favor ensure nausea is
never the reason you miss out on one of
the life's importance
moments right now relief ban has an
exclusive offer
just for uncle joey's joint listeners if
you go to reliefband.com
that's reliefband.com and use promo code
joey you
receive 20 off plus free shipping
and no questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee
when a company does that they're telling
me that they believe in that product
that much so if i was you and i suffer
from nausea
throw me that box mike if you don't mind
nausea airplane sickness
sea sickness car sickness pregnancy
chemotherapy this
hangovers anxiety decision diagnosed
migraines
relief band is the way to go so
if you go to relief band right now use
promo code joey
you receive 20 off plus free shipping
so head over to relief band r e l
i e f b a n d
dot com use promo code joey and get 20
off and get some relief more no more
nausea
number two the joint is brought to you
by
on it my brothers my people my co
i love you i love this product you got
the protein puffs you got the
shroom tech you got the alpha bra if you
don't like pills
alpha brain comes in a powder now you
put it in the shaker you shake it up
same results new mood shroom tech
alpha brain you know immune and i mean
that
whatever you need they got you or it
starts by you just going to honor.com
that's it
go to honor.com and look through the
supplements i can't help you with the
kettlebells or anything
but as far as supplements are concerned
i got you
press in church or joey and get 10
percent off
delivered right to your house no drama
the protein puffs are delicious
you got the korean barbecue you got the
spicy cheddar
just tremendous shroom tech i mean every
product they have
the the melatonin spray now it's known
to
they say it helps to against covert the
melatonin spray
it's flying off the shelves i use it for
sleep so
you know i'm way ahead of the game go to
honda.com right now
press in church and get 10 percent
off and get a box delivered right to
your house on it.com
shirts let's get this party started all
right it's wednesday the 17th
the candles are lit
look who it [__]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here uncle joey's joint
wednesdays february 17th
how you [__] doing i hope
everybody's doing all right out there
before we get started uh my friend
didn't make it today
the [__] snot i had hanging out on my
nose
when i finished the podcast i went in
the bathroom and i saw a snot i saw
something hanging out of my nose
i [__] pulled that [__] out it
was all the way to here and it just went
it was this long i ate that [__]
i
chewed on that [__] like a piece
of gum for 30 minutes
mike didn't even know he's like why
isn't he sharing that joint with me
that's why
because i was chewing on that [__]
booger i love a good booger like that
is tremendous but that's the reason why
you need to weed whack your nose
a shout out to manscape if you [__]
weed out your nose snots won't get cut
there
my buddy called me like 9 30 in the
morning he's like dog
you got to snot your nose and the
podcast i'm like what are you [__]
talking about
i look at the podcast i'm like look at
the size of that thing
i go does it look like a coke rock to
you that was my biggest fear
i go it's a snot the camera in the
microphone i couldn't see it
it was a snot it's not a [__] coke
rock because if not i have the
the [__] d yeah my daughter with
everybody he's doing coke again no i'm
not doing no coke
i just had a tremendous it was
tremendous mic
it had like it looked like a like a
it looked like an alien it had like a
little green head to it
and then like a slimy little body to it
i took it took me a minute to get that
[__] position
you know when you got to get that snot
in position and just [__]
like pull it out and i and i was gonna
throw it away
but when i looked at it it was beautiful
it was nice and gooey
it had some white elements to it like
vitamin d that'll they'll cure [__]
vitamin d
is the [__] cure-all for coving i
took that snot
i rubbed a little on my forehead just in
case and i [__] popped it in my mouth
like a mint
i chewed on that piece of snot for 30
minutes call me a pig
i don't give a [__] put on your relief
ban dude i'm saying if you're getting
nauseated
because
[__] you [__] it's a snot what
do you want from me
it would if it was a coke rock then we
got a [__] problem then then then we
got to go you know you got to talk to
joey pull them aside but
thank god 13 years no cocaine you can't
get me to do a [__] line of coke i'm
petrified
anyway this i can't
i can't i'm petrified with these [__]
pills
i'm petrified with everything you know
why they don't prescribe a lot of pills
to you anymore like 90s because
people od so when they prescribe me
myoxis they prescribe them
21 and they want you to take one every
eight hours
but they're not considering pt
and when you go to pt and they [__]
straighten you oh you
so you need one after pt so that's four
a day
so you always come up short so you have
to beg them like call them and beg them
and so what i started doing was not
taking a daytime one
they save it for later just save it for
later because if not
i could live off the it's the nighttime
shin pain that was really killing me
i could live off you know i had pain
before the surgery why do you think i
had [__] surgery
so the leaves and [__] but this pain
you need heavy duty but that's why
and if you take them at night you can't
[__] sleep
really yeah [__] with my sleep i can't
so it's this whole pain drug thing is a
[__] nightmare here's the funny thing
they talk about this opioid [__]
everybody's on opioids
i gotta tell you something i know a lot
of people
on sunday i all i needed was one pill
one pill i i just needed a pill to take
me through sunday after the
afternoon yeah take the edge off and i
didn't have it i did everything ice
baths
i had my wife freeze cups and [__]
rub my my legs with the thing i finally
took that bottle of smoky mountain
remember that that
edible we showed the friendly farm
i took half the bottle and i put in the
tea
and i [__] drank it and that was it
night night irene dog
night night irene i couldn't do it i
couldn't do it and retha helps with the
pain
cbd lion is tremendous with the pain but
there's
there's a point of this leg not anymore
i think i've gone over the
the humpy i got over the hump but today
i want to talk about something that
nobody ever talks about i definitely did
it the wrong way
i definitely did it the wrong way and
this this idea
sparked in my head about a week and a
half ago
and today's my dear dear friend ralphie
may's
birthday he would have been uh i don't
know how old it would have been
it doesn't make a difference uh it's
he's dead four years today so
i don't know how long this podcast is
gonna last
just because uh i've had problems with
this for the last couple days
i'm gonna get together and talk to you
about this
and uh i'm fine now anyway
what happened was this uh
you know we've lost a half i don't know
i i don't know how many
numbers to cover i can't even start to
count or the calculations i don't know
if it's real or not
i just i know one thing is real death is
real whether you died of a bullet wound
or you dyed a covert they put covert on
your thing it doesn't really matter
this is not what this podcast is about
today
this podcast is about learning how to
deal
with a loss with morning
i think right now i think listen i i i
can bring yous over my house
and show you my emails my my facebook
and my patreon and i will i will make
this bet
i will make this bet with you guys that
i will bet 50 dollars that every day
the last six months except for maybe
three days i have gotten a [__] email
from somebody
telling me that either they lost a
grandmother a father
a mother to cancer or not cancer i'm so
sorry kovid
you know every [__] day since let's
just play it
since april i could guarantee you i can
bet you
i'll bet penny is fifty dollars that if
you go through my patreon
you're gonna find the debt every day
except
maybe three or four days
if you don't think this takes a toll on
a guy like me you're wrong
i know where you're coming from when you
send me that email
i know exactly where the [__] you're
coming from
because i was that person i hope you
guys never forget that
and i was 16 of these this what's the
show alone and
naked in an island yeah [__] that
i was alone in 16 when i found
that little woman on the [__] floor
okay and
just that alone is a loft enough to
traumatize
anybody anybody it's the reason why i
stopped doing blow
because i didn't want this great woman
that i have as a wife
to find my fat [__] ass 400 pound ass
on the floor she would have never
recovered from it
how do i know because i know what it
takes to recover from that
half he has found your parents half he
has got a chance to say goodbye
my dear dear friend i talk him off a
[__] rope
once a month because his mom died in
florida and they had to say goodbye on
facetime
i know i make a lot of jokes and stuff
but that's my way of dealing with
[__] morning
you don't deal with mourning by [__]
going to somebody's house
crying you deal with mourning by walking
into somebody's house
with a face of a man and and you're
controlled because if you're controlled
then that'll control them eventually
you'll break down like i did here
but it's morning it takes time
and if you don't do it right you will
end up like i did in a 27-year
addiction or a bad relationship
because you didn't deal with the death
how do i know this let's go to what
started this whole thing
about a week ago maybe 10 days ago i was
on the phone with my dear friend steve
avillo he's been on the podcast before
and we were talking and he was
you know i hope he doesn't get mad at me
for repeating this online he he said
that he was stressed
when his wife was pregnant because
what if he died and left his wife and
kid the way
his dad had passed and he said that he
never dealt with it
and i had to stop him right there i go
avils your dad died a month
a year before my mom your dad died in
78.
my mom died in 79. i go
what did you expect us to do we
did what we knew how to do was going
back to being a kid
do you understand me we went back to
being a kid like i buried my wife
my wife got to bed i buried my my mom
and went to the playground like i went
to like a res
a little thing we ate cold cuts whatever
and right from there
you know you resume life you know when
you when you're 30 and when you're 40
and somebody dies
you feel more of an impact but when
you're young
you go back to your activities you're
gonna suck susie's titties at the prom
thursday night
you know i'm going back to sucking on
susie's titties
thursday night you know and what do we
do so we sweep
that thing under the carpet and what
happens is
you deal with people all day long right
you deal with people
all day long and when does that thought
creep up on you
at night at night when you're alone
it's just you and your thoughts oh my
god
that's when you remind i swear to god
for me that's how it was
i i dove myself into my friends so much
that you know
eight in the morning we're on a bus
going to school
high school i had a job rental lumber
after rental lumber i was home very
lightly a shower
eat gone again because i didn't want my
mind to settle
because if i settled i would think of my
mom's death and i'd make me
want to kill myself i didn't know how to
deal with it
the fir you want me to tell you when it
came back to bite me in the ass
and now you understand my story a little
better
it came back to bite me in the ass five
years later in 1984.
remember when i told you i ended up
homeless
why do you think i ended up homeless
well
that year is where that emotion came out
you know all through those years i was
johnny rocco i was with my buddy
stinky ferny pally we're out every night
we're doing this we're doing that you're
getting your dick sucked
i'm on colorado with jimmy berkel i'm
having a great time
finally something was wrong with me in
84. it was like
i didn't know what it was and you know
the pain was dying to come out the pain
it was in there but i kept tucking it in
tucking it in
tucking it in tuck it in the pain was
there but something wasn't right
i went to visit my uncle he brought up
some memories
and guys after that i [__] spun out
of control
any drug every pill you know whatever i
needed to take to kill that pain
it was and i didn't know what it was i
was 20 [__] years old
i didn't know what pain thought i had no
idea that pain
once you set that pain loose inside your
body
what do you think [__] happens you
don't care
so i didn't care and if then when the
[__] when i finally realized
that finally i mean i thought i've told
you stories about my mother
i i saw them put her in the ground and i
would still go to my house at night just
to see if it was a mistake
i would still go to my house at night to
see if her light was on
that's how [__] up i was that's
and and right now all these i'm not
saying all these are listening to the
podcast but most of you
know people or maybe have a relative
that has passed
and you're going through this exact
thing right now you're throwing
everything at it
so you don't realize what's going on
that you're in pain eventually you're
gonna have to pay the piper
you could either pay me now or pay me
later well
my payments started in 1984 and it
didn't end until 2007
and i threw more pain on top of it i
threw the pain of my divorce i threw the
pain of not seeing my kid
you know any time pain stuck
it would it would lift all those
feelings up lift all those emotions up
and what what happens when you lift all
those emotions up what's the only thing
that they take care of that
forget that it was more
you know that's what happens that's what
happens you got to keep that pain though
so i did it completely the wrong way
and even today today between
ralphie and brody i won't accept it i
i just won't accept it i have not
i have not taken brody's number out of
here
okay not because i'm a scumbag just
i just have it i can't you know
people kept thinking oh look
ralphie right there ralphie right there
you know just it's not it's not
i'm not ready yet and today isn't being
his birthday i'm happy that this
fell on what to say there brody i'm not
lying to you [__]
i'm the biggest [__] when it comes to
morning
because i don't want to deal with it
because it brings up anthony balzano
it brings up dinorah valdez it brings up
dominic speciale
it brings up anybody else who's died you
understand me so that's why i don't like
dealing with it
but now he's been dead for four years
it's time for me to sit down
and write about ralphie and what he
meant to me and
what he wanted from me and i knew that
if i know for a fact
if that couch was a [__] hospital bed
and i walked in there i i know what
ralphie would say to me and what he'd
want me to do with the rest of my life
and i did that i did that i did that
i used to go train on thursdays i used
to train on mondays and thursdays before
i left la
and every thursday was in burbank monday
was in
she took me monday to studio city and
thursday was burbank you don't know how
many times i sat ralphie down i go
ralphie let's do it this way
let's go on the road thursday and do
four shows and come back sunday open for
you you don't have to pay me anything i
don't give a [__]
i just want to help you get in shape
let's work out before you get on the
[__] plane and then you know
so every thursday i would work out at 12
i swear to god
every time i would make the [__] i do
this as the blinker
you know i'm [__] i i use my
blinkers
when i do this to pop the blink and i'd
make a right i would always go i would
always look and go
ralphie this is what you should have
been doing on a thursday morning
was going to a workout we go home now we
eat
and we head to the airport we catch a
five o'clock playing out to whatever
[__]
city we're going to we have a late night
dinner
and friday morning we go do the two
shows at a [__] theater
and we're home sunday we could eat
dinner with our families and monday
tuesday wednesday thursday we could work
out
and be healthy so i know what i proposed
to him
and i know if he was in the hospital but
dying what he would tell me
and i wrote it out and i [__] lived
that life
you know you guys have seen that i've
lost weight throughout the last couple
years
especially after ralphie's death because
i put his name on my
my lifestyle it's not a diet it's a
lifestyle
everything changes you know what i'm
saying so
i wanted to talk to you people about
morning and what does it mean it's like
when when i came here
and i wasn't prepared if you look at the
podcast in october
and some in november joey wasn't with
you it was some other person it was
because i was mourning
i was mourning the death of my life in
l.a the house
my friends you know dean del rey steve
simone
lee rogan redband i was missing them the
comedy store
i had to come to terms with all those
things so think about all the things i
hadn't worn
the last [__] nine [__] months
eight months i've been here six months
on friday
so all these things but this time i did
it right because i wrote about it
when my mother died i did with gods i
just
you know this was my [__] you know
that's what i did to
to take care of the morning when
somebody dies
and you leave that salmon like when my
sister-in-law died
and i drove to delaware and i went to
the wake
i love my sister-in-law and you want me
to tell you something my sister-in-law
loved me
she [__] backed my comedy career she
financed
she was another one of those people that
i was in a bind and i contacted her and
she sent me money without even blinking
an eye
you know it was between this and not
doing the gate you're doing that [__]
gig
go do your gig here's 20 for gas
whatever you need
a suit listen you know what i did when
when i went
i was supposed to do a a guest set that
night
for tim dillon and i drove up to
north brunswick and as i was pulling up
my sister called and she goes have you
spoken to mike and
i go yeah this afternoon family reunion
she goes no everything changed his wife
died
and i remember i just i said i got to
call you back i tried calling mike he
didn't answer
i drove back it's just like a 20-minute
ride and i drove back and
i told my wife that my sister-in-law
died and i didn't cry i wasn't like you
know i'm not one of those people
it takes time with me it takes time with
me
and uh you know i played with the baby
whatever
and then we went to bed and that night i
went in my notebook
and i wrote about sherry her name was
sherry
and i wrote about sherry how i met her
how he came to fall in love you know she
was my
sister-in-law but i loved her as much as
my brother
she had my back when she had her third
daughter alexa
i spent the last four months of her
pregnancy with her every night i was a
personal
butler i was broke i was a mooch and i
was living off her and
and every night i would step mike my
brother would go out
to shoot darts and [__] he's a nut and
he'd go stay home with my wife
and me and her i would smoke pot and
blow the smoke on her face
because she didn't she couldn't smoke
pots so she just wanted me to
blow the smoke at her and she [__]
would give me money go get chinese food
and we watched goodfellas
every [__] night every [__] night
and if i did comedy i'd come home early
and we'd do the same [__] over and over
again chinese food goodfellas
and she'd make me blow pot smoke at her
but she always
pushed for my comedy and she told me
something once
about one of my jokes and i stopped
doing
a joke but my sister-in-law
my sister-in-law died i just came
downstairs and i wrote about and i wrote
about our relationship
how we became friends what she had done
for me
what she had what i had done for her
and what she would have told me in that
casket
as creepy as this sounds when a person
is in a casket and you're looking at
them in awake
you're thinking about your times with
them like with her they had like a
screen like a
led screen and they had like pictures of
the family
and they showed a picture of us the
borgata by a slot machine and my [__]
heart stopped and you know
it was me and her i had a relationship
with my brother
and i had my relationship with my
sister-in-law and i loved her to death
so i came up with the conclusion the
same way i mourned my mother how i came
up
with my mother how i came up with
dominic and anthony and i do this with
everybody
marilyn you know you know marilyn
martinez died in 2007
i stopped snorting coke maybe a week
after that
you know and
in september maryland died november like
third on november first or something
rick ramos's birthday but
in september she had something in her
house
they were like a little party to get
together you could tell
she had a couple days left she wasn't
gonna live
and then we were having a conversation
and she was telling me that if she ever
lived she wouldn't do dirty comedy
anymore
and in the conversation she said she
looked at me and she goes and joey you
have to stop doing cocaine
and i took it like as a message from god
like you know me dog i look for messages
i was like why would me and marilyn be
having a conversation about comedy
and all of a sudden she just comes out
and says i have to stop doing cocaine
well i'll tell you guys a week later i
stopped doing cocaine
and here we are 13 [__] years later
so what i decided to do was every time
somebody dies that's close to me
i think of what they wanted
for me okay
what did they want for that person
you know i want the best for mike i want
mike to
grow up and be a man he is a man he's
got two kids
he's supporting him he's keeping a roof
over his house he's not a convicted
felon he's a gentleman
he brought my wife and daughter
valentine's day presents
and i mean the kid's a great kid he's
living the life that i would want him to
live
he doesn't snort glue he's on time you
know
you think of that person you go what
would that person would have wanted me
to
what what extraordinary thing would that
person want from me
you know i stopped snorting coke the
pain must have gone away you know
my daughter the pain must have gone away
you know whatever all these things
the pain just doesn't go away you have
to kind of deal with that pain
and stick by that [__] deal
in my mother's case i had a girlfriend
i was living in with her for four or
five years
i wasn't giving her a hundred percent of
joe diaz i was giving her
fifty percent of joe diaz because joe
diaz's soul belonged to comedy
and i said that's it this has to stop i
have to give this girl 100
of joey d is or we're not going to have
a relationship
i also have to live the life that my
want my mother wanted me to
be all my mother wanted out of me she
didn't want me to be a lawyer
i mean listen my mother wanted me to my
mother wanted me to go to the army
to go to college and then go fight in a
war she wanted me to actually
shoot people for this country that's how
much she loved america
but the most the things she said to me
10 days before she
died one night is i just want you to
grow up and be a man
and what does a man mean that you go out
[__] everything or
you get your dick sucked every night no
that
you adhere to your responsibilities as a
man
before the podcast started mikey was
here i got a call
from my agent who i loved daily and i
told him about something i'm making a
move
you know i had to make another move in a
different direction
and he was really cool with it and i
told mike this is how
we do it we have to deal with people
like this because if you don't
then you got nothing you have to be
straight with people that's what a man
does
you have to pay your debts that's what a
man does you have to [__]
open up a door you have to do what a man
does
so for me to make my mom's death easier
and dog i did not figure this out at 20.
that's why i had a rough 20. why did i
have a rough 30
because i didn't figure this out i
didn't figure this out till i was 43
years old
and then i quit coke at 44.
i want i wanted to grow up to be the man
my mother wanted me to be
i stopped doing coke and i became the
man
my mother wanted me to be i own a home
i have a daughter i have a wife i have a
great relationship with my wife
she you know my wife calls me spider
right from good fellas
you know that right my wife thinks i'm
an idiot so she calls me spider spider
right so
we people don't know that's my other
nickname is spider from good fellas
yeah please we have a great relationship
i am very lucky i treat her like a man
you know she's going away this weekend
uh with my daughter they're going skiing
and [__] i can't obviously what am i
gonna ski with one leg
you know she was upset like she came to
me and she's like i don't
i don't want to go because it's your
birthday
we're going to have a great weekend i'm
like [__] you
i'm 58 years old i've had my
share of [__] birthdays my birthday's
friday
we'll get a carvel cake we'll go to
uncle vinnie's
not them i'll come back i'll hang out
with you guys and then you guys could
leave saturday morning
she goes yeah well that's when we were
going to leave anyway i go so what's the
big deal
why do you feel guilty about leaving a
saturday
and she goes well i wanted it to be a
whole weekend i was going to make your
pineapple upside down cake
i'm like do i need a pineapple upside
down cake
we're just going to make a carvel cake
on friday we have a tradition at the
house we need a car belt cake
why would i want to buy you know so i
said go and she was like are you serious
and i'm like go that's what a man does
it's not about me it's about that little
girl why'd we move here
you think we moved here for me to be on
broadway tap dancing with fred is stan
no
we moved here so my little girl could be
a normal little [__] girl
so friday saturday her i think
four moms and one dad only one dad is
going
one dad is going with like like [__]
12 kids
and they're renting some [__] thing
yeah no they got i got thing i think my
wife got a
my wife got a suite for her and one of
the other moms
but yeah that's what a man does i'm
living a family
i have a family now i have a life you
know
okay yeah i don't do comedy every night
no more but now i'm enjoying this part
of it
so when somebody passes your easiest
path
to mourning and i [__] hate myself
for this
is right out this is
i know it's getting old but this is
everything
and it's just three or four sentences
and i swear to god the pain goes away
when i first did it the pain went right
away just acknowledging that i did it
i remember going into that living room
we lived in a one-bedroom
room you know and i remember sitting on
the couch going
i just lost oh wait and then and then
you write letters to them
then i wrote a letter to my mother so
it's like a three process it's like a
two
three process thing you say a prayer
you write out the person whatever your
aunt you have one of those ants
then you go to the house they always
give you three bucks and they always say
oh i can't wait to see you in a play or
whatever
you don't want to do a play you know
what go to a local theater group and do
one play
just in the name of your aunt one play
and once the play is over don't do it
again i'm just using a play
as an example i forgot today's ash
wednesday
anyway [__] i gotta go get my ashes
later on
in fact we'll do it here
[Laughter]
i'll do my own ass wednesday i gotta
find out what i'm gonna give up for lent
this year i always give up something i
gotta go for something for lent
but no that's that's everybody's morning
right now man
and my heart goes out to you and your
families
and you can make this hard or you can
make this real easy
alcohol does help i'm not gonna lie to
you you know
but it's just a [__] band-aid and
it'll haunt you
for [__] ever it'll haunt you
you don't the way the brody and whatever
haunt me
i didn't go to brody's send off i didn't
i don't do those things because i don't
do well in those
i want to deal with it internally
because that's the only way to deal with
it but you saw it you saw i still have
that
i'm a loser but i've already written out
like i wrote out what brody wanted out
of me you know i know what brody would
tell me
and his [__] death pad now you know
that doesn't take
be positive you know the whole [__]
thing you know
i'm sorry but guys this is the only way
i could deal with this [__]
you know so uh for him i try to keep him
more positive
you know for brody every day when i wake
up i have a little picture of my look at
him like oh
i got to be positive think strong you
know yes
yes uh i know he'd want me to be a great
comic
i know that he would smack me in the
face if i told him i was retiring
yeah he would hit me in the face get the
[__] out of here
you know um with ralphie
i knew it what he was gonna tell me
because
ralphie loved when i killed ralphie
loved it
ralphie and joe rogan love when i go up
there
and would not just go off but go off
like they didn't ralphy and joe rogan
didn't want me to have a good set
they wanted me to go off they want to
see people walk
they want to see people fainting and
they want to see
women crying that's what they want out
of here if that's what they wanted
that's what i went for with ralphie rafi
would tell me
player when you go up there and do that
[__] that [__]
if you want it you got it you know i
mean
it's you got to remember guys that
ralphie and i were
uni you know people always [__]
when you're on rogan it's always so good
when ralphie's on your show listen
friendship you know there's no reason
why
two bears in the cave is so good
they're great friends they've known each
other for years they live
and they breathe to one another when you
have two people who breathe for one
another doing a podcast
and they're both funny you got yourself
a [__] problem
when i would do a podcast with ralphie
you would [__] die
laughing before during and after the
[__] podcast
you know whether it was the one with
burke chrysler when he fell through his
dollhouse
and [__]
or it was just look at the yellow
you look at the yellow and all that [__]
i mean we laughed our ass off you know
the
the stronger the bond the better your
podcast you're gonna get
who are the best two podcasters i did
podcasts with
ralphie and joe rogan the best
i listened to the one ralph who won the
other night when he went off on russians
in the beginning like why are you going
off on russians
he told me later on that night because
the guy that
sold him attire was rushing and he beat
him and
you know ralphie always had his [__]
things but
i talked to the smash brothers cory and
chad
i reached out to them uh last night
and told them you know tomorrow's the
day
and i had to verify what year he died i
don't even know when he died 2017.
so it's time for me to start doing some
paperwork
it's time for me to eventually erase
this [__] number
you know one of my biggest guilts from
l.a
was that i was leaving ralphie's spirit
there
i i mean he's buried in arkansas we got
him the [__]
tombstone i'm i'm all good
but some part of me still feels guilty
that i didn't bring his spirit back on i
don't even know
if that's right but mike you're probably
right he probably is right there right
there
i had some weed missing that fat [__]
probably stole it
uh you know when you have
i think one of the best things about
comedy
isn't the traveling isn't the money
performing is one of the top things for
me
and but the top thing is the friendships
that you make through
comedy like it's different than a
regular friendship
and for him and i it was
i i can't tell you how much he helped me
i mean i can't tell you how
i like mike i love mike
i know mike lives in jersey somewhere i
i don't give a [__] where he lives you
know what's happening i mean i i
don't give a [__] away he lives i know
he's in jersey i know he's a jersey guy
and i love him either way ralphie loved
me so much
he's like play i'm coming to that north
bergen
i'm like sure you are he's like i'm
coming to north bergen
i'm gonna wait to you then i'm gonna
come and get you
probably 19 i met ralphie
maybe 97 and by 99 ralphie came to
mothbergen
i was in north bergen and ralphie came
to jersey this was way before ralphie
blew
up okay ralphie nobody knew who ralphie
was
just the people in houston texas it was
me and ralphie living in that building
with that [__] crew of people
god bless their soul gavin celine
rest in peace jody stacy
i mean we had a great [__] building
my man ricky cruz kicking ass down in
miami
we had a great [__] crew we were a
family and me and ralphie sat there and
we wrote
so many [__] jokes together there's a
special ralphie's with a yellow
leather jacket watch that listen to that
special
and tell me that that's not him and me
writing together this
couple of his specials it was just me
and him jenning and i never
made him [__] write it on there that
i wrote i don't give a [__] he's my
brother the guy fed me when i needed
when i [__] needed food you know he
gave me money when he became a superstar
he [__] supported me that guy
when everybody else was giving me
chocolates he was giving me stacks of
bills you know when i got surgery my one
shoulder i couldn't work one month
he came right over and gave me cash this
wasn't about that stuff
i would never i've never even repeated
this about the specials it was just me
and him like just talking
and writing [__] and he would say let me
let me take that take it i don't give a
[__]
what am i a [__] what do i give a
seinfeld i don't give a [__] take it i
don't give a [__]
but one of the best stories i remember
about me and ralphie
if there's one story that i love about
me and ralphie
was i'll tell you this i'll make it
quick
uh there used to be a club called
spellbinders
in houston texas in the the late 90s
mid-90s whenever ralphie got into comedy
you had the uh comedy that the one
family owned outside
there was three comedy clubs um
there was the last stop the lab spot
there was spellbinders
and then there was martin danny
martinez's room
there was four rooms ralphie cut his
teeth
on danny martinez's room everybody else
called him fat and [__]
danny was his mentor you know danny
was also very good to me i think danny's
gotten out rest in peace
but ralphie would go to spellbinders
from time to time
this is a true story i guess he went to
the owner of the danny one day and he's
like hey
i'm gonna go to spellbinders and danny's
feelings got hurt you know club owners
usually do they get hurt they're like
you know you [__]
but you can't get hurt it's just a
business
ralph we went over the spellbinders 20
minutes into his
set he fell through the stage you can't
[__] write this
okay you can't [__] write this at all
so i never knew about it
you know after we became friends like
after like maybe
three months somebody said to him
in front of me and he turned [__]
pale
he was embarrassed because he knew i
wouldn't let it go
okay he knew i wasn't gonna let it go
so you know the lady who booked the
place her name was either lynn carnes
or kim corns who's the hack who's the
singer
kim kim kards or something like that
lincoln
anyway it doesn't really i think her
name was lynn kahn
i think don't fact check me on this
this is 30 years of reefer you know
40 more like [__]
45 years so
he went through the stage and then he
sued him
which made it worse so
he wasn't allowed to play the club so i
i didn't know
i go to houston you know with rogan and
i go let me call spell behind this and
see if i can do like this guest spot
maybe i could work in there you know the
last
stop was a great club i was working
there as a feature
but if i could come down here and put a
couple feature weeks together
i could stay in houston you know you got
beaumont you got new orleans
you got all that [__] down there you
know so
uh i called the lady from spellbinders
i'm like hi my name is joey diaz
uh i like to do a guest spot and she's
like you can't this weekend
but next time you're in town you're more
than welcome to stop by
and that process is when i found out
about ralphie may
so i i
you know somebody said something to him
i'm
i was doing something he didn't think i
heard it but i heard it
so again i didn't tell him it was like
when lee got the hand job
in vegas from the chinese [__]
[__] place
and larry told me right away i didn't
tell lee right away
i gave lee like six weeks the same thing
i did to ralphie i didn't
tell ralphie i knew that he fell through
the stage right away
i gave him like six weeks you know and
one day we're talking about comedy clubs
and i'm like tell me about spellbinders
and he just he just looked at me like
what do you know and i'm like did you
really fall down the stage to spell by
this
he's like jesus [__] christ people
start rumors
there was a little hole and it kept it
wasn't just me
it was it was a hole that kept cracking
and then
ralphie you went through the [__]
stage so he's like
yeah it was a long time ago and blah
blah blah but then he sued her
that's how he bought the forerunner and
all that [__] so
uh you know kim karms or lynn carnes
didn't want to hear
a word of ralphie may like nothing
so that's it you know what i don't need
to work
spell behind this you know i was gonna
now i was gonna work the lap stop a lot
more
he gave me a week with bobby sladen so i
would call her every day
i would get somebody to call her every
day and go hi my name is mike
uh i'd like to do a guest set ralphie
may referred me
and you would hear the crack in her i
would call her in front of ralphie
i would i would be with ralph and then
he go what are you doing i'm calling
spellbinding to see if they give me a
weekend
he'd go put that [__] phone down
they're going to watch highland
my name is pete patello ralphie may
referred me can you
and she just hang up on me because so
many people were doing it to her
like referring them to from ralphie mae
that she knew
it was a [__] prank of some type and
that was the end of that song yeah she
had a change of no they closed down in
fact
they sold they closed down and then the
improv
moved into spellbinders now they moved
out across the street into a bigger
location
but it's been four years brother and i
[__] miss you i miss you
i miss you a lot i learned a lot from
you there's no two people that i learned
more about this business than you and
joe rogan
you both had two different styles but
you did it your way like [__] sinatra
and that's why i love you
ralphie taught me things that
he knew things about comedy i never even
thought of knowing
ralphie was a real comic he knew
little things that would make your
[__] head blew up
and he taught them all to me he showed
me his bag of tricks
and i got a bag of training that's what
it is it's just trickery
it's just like [__] being a magician
ralphie had tricks
and he was that way ahead of the [__]
game
he would tell me about those tricks and
that's why i'm the comic i am today
it was a ralphie man joe rogan man
but the ralphie
you know i got upset in the beginning of
the podcast and whatnot
i've mourned them as much as i can in
the way that i've written about them
like i didn't
make the mistake i made with my mother
and other people who passed
like with brodie and and ralphie i've
done it right
i've written about them i've gotten out
of my system
i'm still not at the point to get them
out of my phone
that takes time that's maybe one more
year give me one more year maybe next
year
i'll take it out of my iphone but
morning is rough guys it's not something
that happens overnight
you know i once described it if you
watch
the documentary when you lose a loved
one or you lose your mother
for me this is the simplest way i could
put it
it's like eating food with no salt on it
the rest of your life
i still got a life i'm very happy i have
a daughter i have a wife
i have great friends i have a deer
community
but my mother's not in my world and
that's [__] rough
that's rough she never got to see all
this
i'm not crying i'm not complaining but
it's rough
and i know a lot of years have gone
through this without a mother an
aunt an uncle a grandfather grabbed a
notebook
two things what did that what would they
say to me on their deathbed
what would they want from me what
great quality would they want me to put
out there of mine
think about it you know with ralphie he
always told me you're the best
storyteller player
you got you go he would tell me not even
to go on stage and tell jokes because
you're wasting your time
just go up there and tell stories just
go up then tell stories and i wouldn't
listen to him
ari [__] put that thing together i
watch those things that's because of
ralphie ralphianari
that that that's that's what it
basically is so all this [__] that you
see online all the [__] that you read
among
that had nothing to do with me my
friends
were my comedy community was solid
rogan josh wolfe ralphie may
you know we were solid over there stan
hope
there was a time when that was the
neighborhood
vista these are streets i'm calling
that go in a row was josh wolfe
gardner was ralphie may
sierra bonita was nick apollo
and mitch hedberg and kirsan was doug
stanhope
those were four la blocks next to each
other
what education is better than that to
have those floors [__] neighbors
how lucky was i and i did something that
a lot of people don't do
i took advantage i took advantage of
that
i asked questions i never stopped asking
questions
even though what's with the questions
you know what i mean comedy stuff you
know like just
talking rapping that was all we did
was talk comedy there wasn't sports it
wasn't girls it wasn't about blow jobs
all we did was the art of comedy that
was what those guys
i'll never forget one day doug stanhope
called me up and he's like yo man i
don't know what's going on
but [__] i came home and ralphie was
making out with my mother
and i caught him and now he ran away i
can't
he sped off with his car so i'm like
what are you talking about
and i get in my [__] car and i fly
over the raft to
doug stanhopes and there's ralphie and
doug stanhope's mom laughing at me
they were playing a prank on me there
they said that ralphie took off with
stan hope's mother so stan hope didn't
know what to do
stand up [__] me in the ass that's why
stanhope was trying to [__] with me and
he's like
i don't know what to do i caught ralphie
making out with my mother
and [__] when i when i uh confronted
them
they both ran off ralphie was there with
me
when [__] doug stanhope's mother
doug stanhope's mother used to save cats
that were all missing
something an ear and eye a leg
so one time we were all over there and
mrs stanhope had
one of the cats died and she put a towel
down
with a shrine with a cat the dead cat
with the with the dead cat on the on the
towel
and like candles like awake and all the
cats
sat around looking at that cat and me
and ralphie are like
look at those cats they're probably
looking at each other going hey
i could use that ear nah i could use
that tail
hey i could use that [__] tooth
because every one of her cats was
missing something
an arm a leg so this is the [__]
this is the you know guys when i go
deep you know this is why i can never
have depression
i won't let myself come with depression
no matter how sad i get sometimes
no matter how much i beat myself up
no matter because i'm [__] rough on
myself
no matter how bad i'm feeling about
something when i think of these stories
with ralphie
i just think a ralphie i just think of
ralphie
and i'll laugh just if the just the
dollhouse
cracks me up never mind that doug
stanhope's mother
never mind the the [__] when he fell
on gardiner
and i'm trying to pick him up and i
couldn't and i told him that i couldn't
pick him up because the cops were going
to come
they were going to think i was mugging
him and he had to get him by himself
because there we are the middle of the
street in front of the fire department
and i'm tugging on one arm i can't pick
him up he's four [__] 500 [__]
pounds you know
whenever i i get down i'm on a plane
something's not going my way
i think about ralphie i think about
brody
you know i don't ever want to forget
about brody i don't want to forget about
browfie
you know i don't know when brody's
birthday is i know brody died around
february
i think i don't remember either
i think i was going because i i found
out
about brody when i got
on a plane when i went to sit down steve
simone
called me that was a long [__] hour
flight and i had to
perform that night so
i threw my performance out out of
respect for brody stevens that night
but back to the topic we were talking
about forget about brody
and forget about ralphie rest their
souls i love yous both
happy birthday and having ralphie uh
i know you people are going through a
lot and i know that you people
either know someone or
have lost a dear relative or whatever
and
you're moving through life like nothing
happened
and you think you're okay that's okay
but something happened and you have to
address it at some point in your life
if not it will come back to haunt you
i'm not talking about
that aunt that lived in connecticut that
you hardly seen
i want you to have empathy for her and i
want you to pray for a lighter candle
for a yeah
i'm talking about those people that are
really special now in your life
that when they go you're left [__]
lost
you're just left there lost you don't
know how to [__] the field
i answer those messages every [__]
day you know some kid hit me up
yesterday
again very anonymous i'm not here to
talk about names
a guy on patreon said he lost his mother
last week
and he goes now i want to thank you for
every single word you've ever [__]
said
and it just destroyed me
it destroyed me because that's what i'm
here for
guys i'm not here to [__] make you
laugh
i'm not here to [__] have a snot
[__] out of my nose
i'm here so you guys can learn from me
from the mistakes i made
don't do this [__] all the dumb [__] i
did growing up and stuff it was fun
while it lasted
but i want you guys to learn to do it
the right way
and not to put up with the [__] i put up
with you don't have to put up with this
[__]
if you if you're not a junkie like i was
you're a comic
like like like jim florentine or you're
a decent [__] person
and nobody's gonna give you [__] you
have to stick up for yourself ralphie
you know
this is why i do this podcast not
because i'm better than you
or any of that [__] because you could
learn from me
you could learn from my [__] mistakes
and one of the biggest mistakes i made
was not mourning my mom right it turned
me into a
[__] junkie and it took
the grace of god for me to understand
morning
and that's what made this process a lot
easier
when mike called me he said we're
starting this up october 1st
i had already written out my morning was
i prepared
i wasn't prepared but eternally
i was getting there i was working
towards it and here we are today
we're at like 87 right now i'm at like
87 percent
if i tell you something i don't want you
to get excited about it
i'm excited about it i actually got
excited last night
about doing stand-up this weekend so
don't believe joe diaz he doesn't know
if he's gonna [__] retire
what are you listening to that [__]
idiot for what are you listening to me
for
it's the truth nobody knows what the
[__] gonna go on right now
as of last sunday i felt so shitty
or monday or even last week because i
haven't been on stage guys
that's why i feel shitty i figured it
out i have not been on stage since
january 4th
so this weekend last night i was making
some tea and i'm like
i'm pretty [__] excited i get to try
out
one new joke i got one joke i got
confidence on
so if you're expecting a bunch of new
jokes don't come on friday because i got
one new bit i got confidence in
all the other stuff i've written i don't
have the confidence relief band the
alpha brain has you know what i'm saying
on it i don't have that type of
confidence to tell you
you could get your money back cause i
don't know
but we're gonna try our best i'll tell a
couple stories
we'll tell a ralphie may story or
something
and uh we'll pull it through but i am
excited this weekend about doing
stand-up
that makes me [__] excited that i'm
excited about doing stand-up
i'm sorry about my cousin the snot that
came out last week
you know and i felt them there for a
minute but i didn't want to dig in front
of you because then you're like joy was
digging for [__] snots
on the podcast what type of [__]
american is he
and then i had to eat it yeah because
i'm not letting that go
at the other sometimes i'll just put on
the table like a piece of gum
and save it for later but then the snot
gets too hard
and you gotta you know jump into a
little bit and i got new teeth
i don't want no problems you know what
i'm saying i want i want to save my
teeth i don't have to go back to [__]
l.a and see the [__] dentist again
but with that in mind listen man i'm
sorry about
any of the losses in your life and
the bottle and drugs is not
the [__] answer to morning it's a
paper
it's a pen it's devotion
it's going back
to square one what that person wanted
for you your father wants something
special for you your mother wants
something special for you
your sister saw you dance one day by
yourself in the shower
and she thinks you're a great dancer you
should be a dancer you're like nah
you know what i'm saying so when
somebody dies
those are the questions you have to ask
yourself what would they say to me in
the casket
what would they thank me for
and what
is the person they would want me to
become
like i'm not saying change i'm saying
that
tighten one of your angles something
that you're doing isn't tight just
tighten it up a little bit joe you're
cursing too much
joey you're doing this you know and
that's what it is
just try to
become what that person thought
you could be you know i never thought i
would end up here
but my mother thought i could i never
thought i could grow up to be a [__]
man i was a [__] punk little [__]
but i grew up to be a man so if somebody
believes it
there's a reason follow it and become
that person for them
and the mourning process will be tip top
magoo
you know i cried because of ralphie
because i haven't mourned ralphie
but i could talk about my mother all day
long and i won't [__] cry i'll get
upset i could talk all day long about
anthony balzano
and not cry and get upset i could talk
about dominic especially
i could talk about a lot of people that
i've lost and not get upset
ralphie and brody are still four years
brody's probably two years right
probably's probably two years yeah and
i'm not even it'll be like maybe ten
years
for me to uh mourn those guys
this was an easy morn the l.a moon it
got easier when i saw the smile on my
daughter's face
when i saw my daughter saying this has
been the best day of my life i got white
castle today
okay if white castle makes you better
and if that's the best day of your life
[__] it la is dead and that's it for the
podcast i got no dates
all i have is uh february 19th
and 20th this week at vinnie's which is
sold out the 24th at vinnie's
which is next wednesday and then all the
wednesdays at vinnie's
in march and then we'll decide from
there what we're gonna [__] do
but from the excitement i had last night
about getting on stage friday
who the [__] knows who the [__] knows
listen guys i love you guys
i want to thank all our sponsors for the
week but most importantly
i want to thank you guys for having my
back every week for watching
uh we keep growing we're getting better
every week and we're getting stronger
and it's because of you thank you very
much thank you for putting up with the
snot and not report me to the
authorities
thank you for not spreading false rumors
that joey's back on coke
just thank you thank you for being you
guys i love you guys
patreon three five and ten bucks
and i'm around it's twitter facebook you
know i'm around mad flavor
stay black i love you [__] have
a great weekend
all right i want to thank you savages on
a beautiful wednesday morning
for uh checking in and enjoying the
podcast
it wasn't the podcast you really wanted
to hear today
it was a tough one on me too but that's
what life is all about
is dealing with things before we leave
listen
i gotta talk to you about something a
lot of people going through a lot of
things stress
you know things are going on you lose
your focus
if you want your focus back it starts
with alpha brain i love alpha brain
memory and focus back a couple days you
have some colored dreams
you do a cycle and you just do it try it
one time
you're gonna be hooked like i am and if
you don't like pills they got the powder
and it's delicious you just open it up i
think it has three different flavors
tremendous
you got the protein puffs you got the
melatonin spray
they got a peanut butter chocolate
protein bar seven grams of protein just
like an egg
tremendous what do you think i eat at
night when i'm when i'm sitting there
and i want a snack that's exactly what i
eat a little protein bar
peanut butter cup go to honey.com right
now unbelievable
unbelievable unbelievable if you don't
like alpha brain
they're not only gonna that they're not
only gonna not send you your money back
you're gonna get your money back but
you could keep the product again like
relief ban when you do
when when you do a statement like that
you're telling me you believe in your
product 150 percent
that's why i trust on it that's why i go
with the shroom tech immune
and the shroom tech sport and the
protein pubs and
go to honor.com right now press in
church
and get 10 off delivered right to your
crib on it
the smarter way to go the joint is also
brought to you by
relief band like i told you in the
beginning you know a third of americans
suffer from nausea
a third of americans suffer from nausea
i don't know what to do
i'm not really that type i only get
nauseated when i see a couple things
but i'll tell you what that's why i'm
excited about my new partner
relief band relief band is the number
one fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
relieve and prevent nausea and vomiting
the product is 100 drug free it doesn't
make you drowsy and has
zero zero side effects this is the kind
of stuff this band
you can only get at a hospital patient
but now it's available
to everybody that means you and how it
works is this let me tell you something
you don't even need to be clinically
proven it got proven by me like i told
you in the beginning
i went to pt one day i forgot to put it
on i figured i
don't need it today on the way back sure
enough
i puked off and i puked twice twice that
day so
i don't like puking you don't like
puking nobody likes nausea
it helps with recuperation it helps with
sea sickness it helps with everything
this is an amazing band it blocks the
signal from your brain
sending it to your stomach telling you
that you're sick
that's science like my man thomas dolby
was telling you
in 1980 anyway relief band is the only
over-the-counter wearable band
that has been used in hospitals and
oncology clinics
to treat nausea and vomiting like i told
you guys
this works how do i know because i just
had surgery
and i haven't taken it off in five weeks
it's gonna be six weeks on friday
my birthday also so anyway uh ensure
nausea never
is the reason to miss out on life's
important moments
right now relief band has an exclusive
offer
just for uncle joey's joint listeners
you ready you go to reliefband.com
use promo code joey and you'll receive
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee
so head over to relief band
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use promo code joey
for 20 off and get some relief all right
i want to thank you guys i want to thank
relief band and i want to thank annette
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank
cbd lion i want to thank
stamps anybody who sponsors us we love
you we got your back
thank you for having our back and you
guys at home we love you listen have a
great week
uh i love you guys thank you for all the
birthday wishes
and i'll see you guys monday morning tip
top magoo ready to [__] go
i love you [__]
[Music]
so
you